Wehe, wehe irgendjemand schickt ein fucking Podcast-Ufo-Intro mit diesem Rhythmus, er wird sofort gelöscht, er wird sofort gelöscht.
Wer war Südko? Podcast Ufo, con Stefano y Florentino. Oh, si, hola, qué tal, hola, Foto, Foto, Foto,ünzen, ich sitze eher auf so halb geschmolzenen Schokomünzen, wo so zwei, drei echte Münzen drin sind, aber ich habe vor Jahren schon vergessen, welche es genau sind und deswegen halte ich erstmal alle fest, damit mir keines durch die Krallen geht. Und anders als bei dem Auge, was aufgeht und dann fies aufbleibt, geht deines wieder zu.
Ja, meines geht schon zu. Auge wieder. Ich glaube, du sitzt auf einer sehr schlecht sortierten Dropbox.
Ja, das ist eine andere Fantasy-Geschichte. Es gibt die Legende des Drachen Florentin, der sitzt auf einer unsortierten Dropbox, da könnten wichtige Files drin sein, man muss sich aber erst durchsagen.
Ich meine, haben die Hobbits oder die Zwerge oder die Gnome oder Kobolde oder was in diesem Fancy Schwachsinn da, haben die sich explizit Gedanken gemacht, was die wirklich mit diesem Goldschatz machen.
Weil die rennen da irgendwie einmal durch die halbe Dalaran da durch, die Walachei, und dann sind sie, töten den Drachen oder was auch immer, dann haben sie diesen riesigen Goldschatz und dann erstmal so, da ist ja viel Staub, wie macht man das? Wenn wir jetzt eine Kette, wenn wir uns nebeneinander stellen, dann können wir alle bis ins Auenland uns das so durchreichen. Okay, wir sind elf Zwerge, wir legen eine Strecke von 25 Metern zurück, maximal. Von, wie viel brauchen wir? Die Hälfte von uns haben auch noch ungewöhnlich kurze Arme. Wir sind eh schon Zwerge, aber wir sind unterdurchschnittlich lange Arme. Ich höre nur Complaining, Complaining, Complaining. Ja, ich versuche ja zu überlegen, ob wir vielleicht nicht eine Lösung finden, wo unsere Armlänge nicht so eine große Rolle spielt, weil ich habe ja schon ein paar Mal gesagt, dass ich da nicht darauf angesprochen werden möchte, weil ich habe von allen die kürzendsten Arme und das ist einfach unterdurchschnittlich. Niemandem ist aufgefallenfallen, wenn das nicht ständig betonen würde, wie kurz deine Arme sind. Ich glaube, das fällt einigen Leuten auf. Jetzt fällt es mir auch auf, das ist unproportional, das ist für einen Zwerg unproportional. Ja, es ist einfach, ich habe ein bisschen kurze Arme, also eigentlich sind die Beine länger und dadurch wirken auch die Arme noch mal kürzer. Ich meine, also, okay, meine Idee liegt 25 Meter zurück. Von wie vielen brauchen wir?
Sechstausend Kilometer. Sechstausend, tausend Meter, sechs Millionen, sechs Millionen, davon haben wir 25 mit deiner Lösung. Okay, und wenn man jetzt, angenommen, das kommt hinten an, das Goldstück, und dann stellt sich der, der ganz Außen stand, rechts daneben.
Ja.
Und dann, wie so eine Raupe, können wir das Goldstück, können wir eine Goldmünze dann weiter reichen bis in unsere Zwergen binge bing. Und Raupen sind schon das schnellste Tier. Stimmt, ja. Eigentlich ist es wie so ein Kreiswesen. Es gibt kaum kreisförmige Tiere, die wirklich wie so eine Schlaufe so vorwärts rollen eigentlich. Wie so eine Panzerkette. Hunde versuchen das, Hunde beißen sich in den Schwanz, aber ineffizient.
Das ist sehr ineffizient.
Ich habe nur gedacht, vielleicht können die Adler uns helfen.
Jetzt wieder mit den Scheißadlern, jedes Mal, egal welche Diskussion wir führen, du sagst immer die Adler.
Wir hatten, als wir die Adler getroffen haben, haben wir einen aus dem Gebüsch rausgezogen und der hat uns einen Wunsch erfüllt. Wofür haben wir denn einen Wunsch nochmal eingelöst? Ich wollte abends McDonalds. Du wolltest abends McDonalds und der Adler hat uns von McDonalds geholt. Und dann haben wir erst erfahren, dass es unser einziger Wunsch war. Ich habe auch mit drei gerechnet, aber es war nur einer. So, und jetzt haben wir wirklich keinen mehr. Selbst für unseren Fantasy-Schwachsinn hier ist es kontraintuitiv. Ich dachte auch, dass es in Fantasy-Schwachsinn die Regel ist, drei oder irgendeine Zahl, eine Multiplikation von drei. Ich meine, Tolkien war ja so krasser Linguist und so ein Shit.
Aber sorry, dass es wieder darum geht, by the way, Floating kippt auch um vor Schreck.
Aber glaubt ihr, dass der so geflamed wurde von seinen, weil er war ja der Erste, der so mit Bogen und die Elben und dann kommen die Orks und dann die Trolle und dann bum bum badum und dann Saruman und Gandalf und Gandalf mit dem Stauberstab blitze blitze bum bum. Glaubst du, dass da irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Sir Thomas Atwoodson, sein, keine Ahnung, bester Freund oder Erzfeind, bester Freund gewordener Erzfeind, dann so zu ihm gesagt hat, hör mal, J-R-R-R-R-R. Was ist das eigentlich für ein Fantasy-Schwachsinn? Ja, ich glaube auch, dass so in der Vorlesung, er hält so Vorlesungen über Bio-Wulf, die alten Geschichten, und einer von den Studenten hat so eine Legolas-Perücke an. Und es ist so, come on guys, it's what I do in my free time. Don't judge a man by its hobby. Hobbit. Don't judge a man by its hobbit, hobby. Und der eine Typ mit Legolas Perücke schmunzelt einfach nur und denkt so, come on, das mache ich nebenbei. Das mache ich nebenbei. Bist du noch in deinem Fantasy-Schwachsinn? Und die Frau von J.R. dann so, nein, das ist ihm wirklich wichtig.
Nee, das ist ihm wirklich, das bedeutet ihm was, okay?
Schatz, hör auf, du musst mich nicht immer verteidigen.
Ich meine, du gibst so viel Mühe und du brennst so dafür und du erfindest deine eigene kleine Sprache und der Kumpel so.
Es gibt 15 Ringe, drei haben die Zwerge, neun haben die Menschen. Die Gärtner und dann was jetzt kommt die Elfen jetzt noch. Ja, und die sechs haben die Elfen. Die heissen Nenya, Quenya, Stan, Stella und Legolas. Legolas. Ah, okay, weil du jeden Tag aus deinem Schreizimmer drüben auf die Schmiede Legolas guckst, war deine erste Idee. Ja, genau, weil du so eine Pizzerie um die Ecke hast, die Legolas heisst. Die Gimli heisst. Wo all deine Ideen herkommen. Es wäre so lustig, wenn er in der Straße gewohnt hätte, wo alle Geschäfte, aber das war es für ihn im Funk-Sketch-Format oder so. Ja, genau das stimmt, dass man so zu ihm nochmal geht und dann hat er irgendwie so einen Nachbarn. Das war doch bei der J.K. Rowling gab es ja die Doku, die Unauthorized Documentary, die ich gekauft habe. Wo? Weil ich dachte, ich habe sie auf Amazon als Cvd gefunden. Weil ich glaube, ich habe mir damals die Harry Potter-Filme bestellt und dann habe ich die Unauthorized Biography gesehen und er dachte mir, you had me at Unauthorized. und gross grossartig da werden einfach nur nachbarn befragt und dann heißt es ja sie war eigentlich unscheinbar relativ normale nachbarin ja und so und dann einfach die vorstellung dass die alle dann irgendwie bezug zu haben und einer ist so riesengroß mit so einem grossen bart und dann gibt es den kleinen der und er hat ja also mir ist nicht aufgefallen ich war immer mit meinem unsichtbarkeitsmantel unterwegs und habe ich sie manchmal auf der Strasse gesehen und dann, nee, nochmal den Unsichtbarkeitsmantel und alles.
Ja, denn da liegt der lange Teil meiner Familie.
Und dann abends, also wie man sich hier konzentrieren kann, weil abends mal dieses Motorrad hier durchblärrt, durch diesen kleinen verlassenen Ort, also wirklich, dass in dieser Strasse, wo eigentlich alles ganz und gar normal ist und alle sich freuen, es ganz und gar normal zu sein, blättern dieses Motorrad und dieser alte Mann mit diesem Riech und da kommt alles raus, das ist alles in ihrer Nachbarschaft. Und hinten läuft so ein kleiner Junge mit so einer Blitznarbe vorbei, einfach so. Jacklin, Jacklin, Jacklin. Nicht auf die Narbe ansprechen, nicht auf die Narbe ansprechen. Okay, Wir müssen uns entschuldigen, wirldigung, Huldigung, Huld Sorry, sorry, dafür das sollte so nicht sein. Ein paar Betroffene, gibt es unter euch wahrscheinlich ein paar Größen, beziehungsweise ein paar Artikel machen gerade Schwierigkeiten. Uns wurde nur diese skriptische Nachricht mitgeteilt, da ist was los auf dem Suezkanal. Das ist selten gutes Zeichen. Selten gutes Zeichen. Es geht um den Community Drop, wo ihr dankenswerterweise eure tollen Designs eingeschickt habt. Wir haben Merchler mitgemacht, ihr habt das bestellt, wir haben uns alle gefreut, wir warten ja auch noch auf unsere Produkte. Ja, viele haben es schon, aber auch da draußen, also schickt uns weiterhin Fotos, ihr seht alle ganz, ganz toll aus. Aber leider dieser, ich will es gar nicht sagen, aber dieser verdammigte Suezkanal hat leider, der ist zu oder er ist zu offen. Und wir alle wissen ja, wo er liegt. Richtig.
Und das ist ja ein Nadelöhr.
Es ist ein Nadelöhr zwischen dem Baskischen Meer und dem Roten Meer.
Und da muss der ganze Welthandel der gesamten Welt durch.
Durch.
Einmal wie so eine grosse Sanduhr muss da alles durchrieseln.
Weil oben sind die Trolle und unten die Orks.
Ja.
Und dann muss man da durchstechen. Muss man einmal durch.
Man will da nicht durch.
Bei Gott will man da nicht durch.
Aber man hat auch eine Art, die es jetzt zu. Und da müssen auch alle Wale durch mit der Walwanderung. Leider ist einer dieser Wale genau gegen unser Schiff, das grosse Podcast-Ufo-Frachter-Flaggschiff. Der wurde geschwarzen Wolke auske aus Russ. Völlig unzeitgemäß. Und das Wasser dahinter ist auch pechschwarz. Man weiß gar nicht warum. Also man weiß nicht warum, weil alle Schiffe, selbst diese Riesen-Happag Lloyd und Evergreen, diese Riesenfrachter davor und danach, kommen nicht viel aus dem Schornstein. Ne, eigentlich relativ sauber. Wir haben uns für so ein altes Schiff entschieden. Und dieses Rußöl einfach nochmal durchgeballert wird in grossen Mengen. Rost. Und drumherum alle Delfine schwimmen an der Wasseroberfläche alles tot. Und dagegen sind die dann die Wale gedotzt und leider ist es dann gekennter. Das war ein gezielter Angriff von den Wahlen. Möglich, möglich. Wir können zu diesem Zeitpunkt nichts ausschliessen. Die Rache wird gnadenlos sein, das können wir versprechen. Ich will jetzt ja auch nicht so rumschämen, aber wir wurden tatsächlich immer vertröstet, tut uns sehr leid, uns wurden Termine versichert, die wurden nicht eingehalten. Es ist ein bisschen unglücklich, aber es gibt tatsächlich gerade vielen Merch-Lieferanten so, weil eben alles durch den Suezkanal geht. Die Erde ist schuld, aber wir sind auch ein bisschen schuld und deswegen wollen wir jetzt sagen, sorry, ihr könnt das alles sturnieren, falls ihr keinen Bock mehr habt, ihr könnt alles sofort sturnieren, kriegt alles wieder zurück, kein Problem. Alle Betroffenen haben jetzt eine Mail bekommen, wenn euch der Liefertermin zu spät ist, was wir völlig verstehen können. Könnt es kostenlos sturnieren, das heißt, niemand muss irgendwie Geld bezahlen für etwas, was er nicht erhält oder nicht möchte. Ihr könnt natürlich auch jetzt mit einem Zugticket einfach nach Suez fahren, direkt aufs Schiff und kriegt ihr direkt euer T-Shirt ausgehändigt vor Ort. Das ist eine Möglichkeit, die halten wir offen. Wir empfehlen nur Masken, Masken aufzusetzen, weil das Schiff ist. Diverse Schutzanzüge, das erkennt man von weitem. Das kann ich euch sagen, das Schiff erkennt man von weitem. Wir haben das das älteste schiff gekauft das ist einfach ein bisschen dreckig also wenn ihr den podcast hört und kennt und so ist ich fände es auch weird dann dieses schiff zu dieses riesige schiff zu sehen wo groß das podcast ufo in so einer no bullshit fracht frachter schiff schrift auch draufsteht die flaggen alle gehisst und ist weird ist, wir fanden es im ersten Moment, als wir es im ersten Mal gesehen haben, auch merkwürdig, aber es ist, ja, es steckt da jetzt rum.
Und die Nachrichten-Footage ist natürlich auch bitter, wenn mitten im Suezkanal quer ein Schiff liegt, die ganze Welt berichtet und da steht riesengroß das Podcast-Ivo drauf. Das ist natürlich jetzt nicht die Publicity, die wir uns wünschen. Auf der anderen Seite, welcome to all our listeners, angry, very angry listeners, if you watch like BBC or CNN or ABC or the Indian News Corporation, welcome to the podcast, we appreciate your hate and your angry comments and you won't understand the rest of the episode, so sorry. Okay, so, but I can, we can switch over to English if you want. Yeah, if you want to. And then we...
First of all, sorry for the pollution. It is all black now. It's all dirty. Everything is dirty. All dead and all the corpses of the fish, like stuffed into the canal. Yes, yes. It's full to the brim with dead fish and it's you can't save them ja aber das wollten wir nur kurz ähm das war die
das podcast ufo entschuldigung huldigung huldigung huldigung huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldigung, Huldnahme, das ist eine absolute Katastrophe, ist mir zu fröhlich, passt für mich nicht zum Christentum, weil selbst die fröhlichen Christenfeiertage wie Ostern, ich glaube das erste Ostern war geil, ey Jesus ist zurück, aber spätestens beim zweiten weiss man, der war nicht lange da, der ist dann sofort wieder abgehauen, ist eigentlich auch kein Grund zu feiern, wenn der dann sofort wieder raus ist, der ist ja aufgestanden und dann war er gleich wieder weg. So, das war ja einmal nur so ein, das war wie dieses Wetten, dass Revival. Jeder One-Night-Stand. Zum Beispiel, ja, oder wenn man nochmal sagt, wir machen nochmal eine Folge Wetten, dass. Ja. Selbst die Hardcore-Wetten, dass Fans wissen, es ist nur eine Folge, danach nie wieder. Aufgestanden und dann weg. Auferstanden, sagt man auch. Du sagst immer
aufgestanden, ich finde, das klingt so,
als hätte er ein Nickerchen gemacht.
Ich finde, das ist
diese ganze Jesu, also alles, was
diese Wörter, die man auch hat,
irgendwie um das Ganze ein bisschen heiliger
klingen zu lassen und ein bisschen grösser und
larger than life, deswegen wäre mir schon wichtig, dass du
sagst, auferstanden. Aber es steht nicht in der Bibel, dass
er eigentlich schon eineinhalb Tage früher
hätte rauskommen können,
aber gesagt hat, jetzt habe ich endlich mal meine
Vielen Dank. in den Live. Deswegen wäre mir schon wichtig, dass du sagst, auf erstanden. Aber es steht nicht in der Bibel, dass er eigentlich schon eineinhalb Tage früher hätte rauskommen können, aber gesagt hat, jetzt habe ich endlich mal meine Ruhe. Der wird ja überall erkannt, überall. Oh, kann ich eine Steintafel mit dir machen? Und dann wird das gemeißelt, das dauert ja ewig. Das dauert zwei Stunden für jeden Fan, musst du jeden zwei Stunden Steintafel meißeln lassen. Ab wann, glaubst du, gab es diese Tische an den berühmten orten wo so kleine kreuze verkauft wurden ah ja und hat sich die zeit überschnitten in denen das als souvenir verkauft wurde wegen jesus und es noch leute actually gab die an kreuz ans kreuz genagelt wurden als die gute frage und die dann so da hängen und sagten hallo wie fucking uncool ist das denn und unsentimentar und pietätlos, dass ihr diese kleinen Kreuze verkauft, an denen immer noch mein Schwager ist daran gestorben. Aber ist eine gute Frage, die Geschichte des Souvenirs. Ich kenne nur das Sprichwort Money for Old Rope. Das ist, wenn man sehr leicht Geld verdient, einfach verdientes Geld. Und das kommt daher, dass früher, wenn Leute gehängt wurden, wurde der Galgen in Teile geschnitten und verkauft. In Teile geschnitten.
In Teile geschnitten und verkauft, damit die Leute sagen können,
ah, endlich ist der weg, oder vielleicht hat das auch irgendeine Aberglauben-Gedöns oder so,
dass man dann nicht, keine Ahnung, weiß ich genau,
aber auf jeden Fall konnte man das verkaufen,
und für den Henker war das sehr leicht verdientes Geld,
weil du dieses Seil halt dann relativ
teuer verkaufen konntest.
Wie man die Berliner Mauer immer noch kaufen kann.
Richtig, ja.
Holst ihr euch noch, solange sie da ist, solange sie warm ist.
Da hat mein lieber Freund Mats Frey auch mal gesagt,
Was ist, also, was passiert, wenn die leer ist? Also, oder gibt es schon, gab schon den Moment, wo die Mauer raus ist? Stefan, das ist doch das alte Pizzading. Du verkaufst, wenn du hast eine ganze Pizza und du schneidest ein Stück ab und verkaufst ein Stück. Dann kommt der zweite Kunde, du schneidest wieder ein Stück ab. Dann guckst du aus dem Laden raus und merkst, oh, die Schlange ist noch ganz schön lang. Ich bin so gespannt, wohin diese Richtung. Du schaust aus dem Laden raus und denkst, sie hat noch eine Pizza, die Schlange ist noch recht lang. Ja, was ist das für ein Laden? Und dann fängst du. Ja, ganz kurz, was ist das für ein Laden, die eine Pizza haben? Die macht morgens eine Pizza und dann merken sie, uh, das reicht nicht ganz und dann schauen sie raus. Die haben sehr oft aber grosse Leuchtreklame, Riesenschild, Pizza, okay, das haben die aber alles, aber die brauchen eine Pizza. Genau, die sagen pro Stück einen Euro und das erste Stück schneiden sie so ein Achtel und dann schauen sie aber aus dem Fenster und merken, das sind ganz viele Leute und dann schneiden sie die Stücke immer kleiner und jeder, der kommt, kriegt ein kleineres Stück, so und die wird immer kleiner und immer kleiner und rein mathematisch gesehen kannst du unendlich viele Stücke verkaufen, wenn die Stücke nur immer kleiner werden. Und ich glaube, ähnlich ist es bei der Wiener Mauer auch, dass sie sagen.
Ich hätte gerne ein Stück von der Berliner Mauer, bitte.
Ja, alles klar.
Genau.
Ja, Vorsicht, Vorsicht, das ist, genau, Sie müssen aufpassen, sonst klappt es über, sonst faltet es, Sie müssen es ganz aufrecht nehmen. Ja, weil es ist nichts, es ist nichts, Sie gehen mit Luft. Genau, es ist eine Scheibe, es ist eine Scheibe. Sie nehmen nichts. Ne, das ist, schauen Sie, Sie müssen seitlich ein bisschen drehen, dann merken Sie, es ist fast transparent, es ist eine dünne Scheibe. Ich weiß nicht, ob das überhaupt noch was ist. Das ist die Berliner Mauer, na klar, das ist die Original, Historie in ihren Händen, ein Teil der Geschichte, ein Stück der Geschichte dieser Bundesrepublik. Ist das nicht herrlich? Ja, haben Sie da auch ein Echtheitszertifikat oder so? Also ich habe das Gefühl, es wird wie so ein Kind, so einen Sandkuchen gehen. Naja, guck mal, das ist doch die Berliner Mauer oder nicht? Ja, auch das sieht man nicht mehr so richtig. Sie zeigen auf dem, da steht ein Schild, Berliner Mauer, okay, aber darunter sehe ich nicht mehr, sehe ich nichts mehr. Es ist unendlich klein. Drehen Sie sich mal um, hinter Ihnen stehen noch 450 weitere Leute, die auch noch ein Stück von der Berliner Mauer haben wollen. Ich habe super lange hier angestanden auch. Ja, jetzt freuen Sie sich doch mal. Ja, okay. Wollen Sie ein Stück vom Bernsteinzimmer auch noch haben? Ja, gerne. Gerne, so ein Mauer. Das will keiner hier. Oh, danke, ja, bitteschön, bitteschön. Dankeschön. Achtung, brennt, Bernstein brennt. Bernstein brennt? Bernstein brennt ist, kann man elektrisch aufladen und schwimmt. Habe ich alles gelernt im Prähistorischen Museum, wo ich mir auch einen Stoff Mammut bekommen habe als Kind. Das war lange Zeit mein Begleiter, wurde einmal nass. Prähistorisch. Prähistorisch, ja. Mammuts haben keine Geschichte. Mammuts haben keine Geschichte. Du lernst in der Geschichte. Weißt du was, du hast keine Geschichte. Ja, wenn du die Mammuts so anfeindest. Naja, Mammuts haben, wenn du wissen willst, was habt ihr eigentlich so vor zehn Jahren gemacht?
Da sagen die Mammuts, boah, hui, äh, prehistorisch.
Kein Plan, Kollege. Keine Ahnung. Ich finde das ein ganz merkwürdiges Wort.
Sie sind doch Teil unserer Geschichte.
Wo wären wir jetzt ohne die Mammuts?
Ja, das wissen wir eben nicht.
Die haben uns über die Alpen getragen.
Wirklich? Die haben uns in ihren Hörnern sanft über die Alpen getragen. Warum mussten wir über die Alpen? Um den Ring nach Mecklenburg vor Römer zu bringen. Und dann natürlich den Suezkanal haben wir uns getragen auf ihren grossmächtigen Rücken. Also ich finde das irgendwie weird, dann sagt man prähistorisch. Schlag ein anderes Wort vor. Ich meine, wo ziehst du die Grenze? Alt, super alt. Wo ziehst du die Grenze? Dann sage ich gut, nach den Römern. Okay. Alles davor ist prähistorisch. Okay. Aber das findest du nicht richtig, oder? Ne, das find ich nicht richtig. Es geht ja um Aufzeichnungen, so eine Wandmalerei, wenn da mal jemand was aufgemalt hat oder so, dann ist das schon historisch. Dann kannst du schon sagen, okay, die konnten wirklich nicht malen. Das klingt für mich wie, da wollte jemand ein Museum aufmachen, er hat nur die Reste abbekommen. Ja, das kann sein, ja, auf dem grossen Museumsbazar, wenn du sagst so, Da Vinci, ah, ich war zu spät. Wenn die alle ganz vorne stehen und der eine steht ganz hinten, ah, Mona Lisa, kriegt nichts mehr zu greifen. Tja, Jeff, dann haben wir wohl die ganze Geschichte gekauft. Das waren alle historischen Museen. Tschüss, viel Erfolg mit deinem Museum. Danke, Bernard. Da mache ich eben ein prähistorisches Museum. Gib mir die Mammuthörner, gib mir das Mammuthorn. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie Mammuts klangen. Es ist wichtig, dass du unsere Geschichte war. Und da warst du? In welchem Prähistorischen Museum warst du? Im Prähistorischen Museum? Keine Erinnerung mehr. Ich weiß nur, ich war an einem Tag in zwei Museen. Das ist eine Leistung, die ich heute nicht mehr hinkriege, als Kind ohne weiteres möglich. Und ich war am selben Tag in einem Prähistorischen Museum und in einem Schokoladenmuseum. Und ich weiß nicht mehr genau, wie meine Eltern das gehandhabt haben, ob sie gesagt haben, lass uns erst, weil wenn du erst ins prähistorische Museum gehst und das Kind weiss, im Anschluss kommt das Schokoladenmuseum. Sprintet es durch. Dann sprintet es durch. Wohingegen, wenn du sagst, erst Schokoladenmuseum, ist das Kind so voll gefressen und fett und hat eigentlich für den Tag schon seinen Pensum erreicht, dass es nicht mehr ins prähistorische Museum geht. Nee, du musst schon erst ins prähistorische Museum. Erst Prähistorische Museum, da habe ich das Mammut bekommen, dann waren wir im Schokoladenmuseum von Sarotti, also heißt auch das Mammut Sarotti, und deswegen hieß mein Mammut immer Sarotti, weil ich diesen Tag sozusagen in diesem kleinen Stoffwesen zusammengesteckt habe, und da gab es einen Schokoladenbrunnen, da konnte man Schokolade essen. Da habe ich Schokolade gegessen, aus dem Schokoladenbrunnen raus. Cool, nicht in Köln. Nicht in Köln, das ist ja ein allgemeines Schokoladenmuseum, kein Sarotti-Schokoladenmuseum. Ne, das Lind-Schokoladenmuseum. Toll. I don't know. Ja, ich meine es ist Lind. Hast du eigentlich letztens gesehen, ist es jetzt natürlich, und das sehen wir natürlich kritisch, jetzt schon Ostereier im Supermarkt und so. Sehen wir kritisch. Egal. Und habe ich jetzt gesehen, Frühlingsdominosteine. So. Und jetzt finde ich, ich finde, da ist man zu weit gegangen. Ich finde, da sind wir zu weit gegangen. Dominosteine sind ein Weihnachtsgebäck, das uns die Weihnachtszeit versüsst. Es ist eisig kalt, das Auto springt nicht an, alles was wir haben, um uns zu freuen, ist der Dominostein. Und jetzt ist es fucking Stefan, hey, was ist du da, was hast du da, was hast du unterm Tisch? Wir stehen seit neun Stunden hier in der Kälte in unserem kleinen Ford K, ich will doch nur einen letzten Dominostein. Das ist alles, was wir noch haben bei Doppein. Diese köstliche Melange aus Gelee, Lebkuchen und Marzipan, köstlich umrandet, umwickelt von einer herrlichen Schicht Zartbitter. Und nur noch zu dieser Jahreszeit können wir die essen. Ne, jetzt immer. Ja, ja, cool. Frühlingsdominosteine mit einem Osterhasen drauf, sage ich, nein, stopp, das geht nicht.
Kann da der Papst sich eingreifen und sagen, Freunde, Weihnachten, Ostern sind zwei völlig unterschiedliche Dinge, man kann das nicht vermischen. Wir können nicht zulassen, dass die ganzen Weihnachtsgebäcke jetzt irgendwie noch da in die anderen reingehen. Frühlingsdominostein mit irgendwie Himbeergelee oder Erdbeergelee in dem Dominostein drin, das geht nicht. Ich finde es so lustig, weil der Papst hat eine sehr, sehr starke Meinung zu so Dingen, wo man sagt, warum, äußerst du dich zu Kondomen. Ich finde das immer noch so albern, dass er da, da ist ja auch er der super neue, coole Revoluzza-Papst und er ist ja ach so fortschrittlich, bla bla bla, ist ja nicht von abgerückt, dass Kondome verbrannt gehören und nicht benutzt, warum, auch immer. ich verstehe diese Argumentation auch nicht so richtig und dann,
aber sowas äußert er sich nicht, wo ja wirklich die Feiertage
einmal in so einen Sack
gepackt werden und dann alles durchgewurschtelt
und dann ausgewürfelt.
Und das greift ja schon sehr ein
in alles irgendwie. Absolut.
Und da hält er dann seine Klappe.
Nee, das geht nicht, weil das ist ja dann auch
Lebkuchen in der Frühlingszeit, Sommerzeit, das streitet für mich einfach zu weit. Das geht nicht. Ja, das könntest du alles thematisieren, wenn es meine App gäbe, Lettersnacks, wie Letterbox nur für Snacks, habe ich vor ein paar Folgen hier mal gepitcht, kam nichts zu. Von niemandem, niemand hat Lust darauf, noch ist es dann in der Verlängerung zu programmieren. Da könntest du reinschreiben, nicht mit mir,
ich rufe zum Boykott auf. Wäre natürlich auch ein gutes
Spionagetool, damit ich sehe, welche meiner Freunde
sich diese Frühlingsdominosteine
sehen. Dann tauche ich eines Nachts bei denen auf
und zertrümmere denen die Knie.
Ich bin eine, eine...
Die Dominosteine, aber wir gehen dann doch so weit.
Ja, ja, ja. Ich zertrümmere denen
die Knie und verlasse unerkannt wieder
die Wohnung. Nee, alle erkennen dich. Und dann sollen sie schon... Moment mal, du meinst, man würde mich in einem schwarzen Latex, hautengen Latexanzug mit einer Brechstange in der Hand. Du könntest mich von hundert Eindringlingen. Nein. Am Gang. Von hundert schwarzen Latex Eindringlingen mit Brechstange könntest du mich erkennen. Woran genau? was an meinem Gang ist so charakteristisch? Ich kenne dich schon sehr gut. Ich weiß genau, deine Silhouette jetzt. Ich brauche nicht mal, ich brauche wirklich nur die Silhouette. Ich brauche nur die Silhouette. Ich sehe dich vor so einem riesen, comichaft grossen Mond mit so katzenhaft rausklettern in deinem Latexanzug und ich zeige mir hunderttausend, zeige mir tausend Leute, ich sag dir, das ist der Florentin. Jetzt übernimmst du dich, jetzt übernimmst du dich. Stefan Tietze aus Carmen Wetter. Ja. Das gesamte Publikum kriegt schwarze Latexanzüge an und ich sitze auch im Publikum, auch sitzend. Puh, ja. Okay, gut, okay. Auch sitzend und du musst durchs Publikum gehen und musst mich finden. Jede Woche sehe ich deinen Umriss. Wir stehen auf der Bühne zusammen. Ich kenne dich von allen Seiten in und auswendig. Das ist schön. Das ist wirklich schön. Ich weiß genau, ich weiß genau. Ich würde dich im Leben nicht erkennen, wirklich. Ich habe schon so oft Leute in der Frühstückgängerzone von hinten angesprochen und gesagt, Hi Stefan, hey, hallo, hallo Stefan, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey,ier Landruth oder sowas, wo man denkt, wie kann das denn passieren?
Riesenzufall, riesenzufall.
Ja, ja, ich weiß es auch nicht.
Also ich glaube, ich kann dich da gut erkennen.
Ich finde es ein bisschen drastisch, dass du die Bandscheiben leberst, die Knie zertrümmert. Knie zertrümmert, beide in Schürt und Asche, die Kniescheiben komplett zerstört.
Ja, ich glaube, da könnte ich nicht mehr laufen, bin ich ehrlich. Du musst dann laufen, dass du immer so die Knie in die Schuhe reinmachst. Und dann sieht es immer so aus, als wärst du ganz klein und könntest nur noch so laufen, wärst trotzdem noch grösser als ich. Wahrscheinlich. Kann gut sein, aber ich kann es dir gut gehen. Also meine Rückenschmerzen sind komplett behoben, deine auch. Sehr schön, das freut mich, das freut mich. Wir sind alle komplett genesen, wir sind kerngesund. Wir sind wieder in der Phase, wo wir nichts für unsere Gesundheit tun müssen, denn der akute Anlass ist nicht gegeben. Nein, er ist nicht gegeben. Ohne akuten Anlass mache ich nichts. Gar kein Problem. Ohne akuten Anlass tue ich nichts. Mein Körper ist ein Wrack, mein Körper ist ein Wrack, ohne akuten Anlass mache ich gar nichts. Ja, also mir ist alles scheiss egal, jetzt wird wieder gelebt, jetzt wird wieder Gewichte werden in die Höhe gestreckt, als wir haben jetzt gewesen. Ja, jetzt lässt du dich wieder gehen, jetzt lässt du dich wieder gehen und hebst die Gewichte. Deine Form von jetzt lasse ich mich gehen ist, ich heb Gewichte hoch. Ich strecke die Gewichte in die Höhe. Deine Fahrer sind auch anders, aber ich lasse mich auch komplett gehen, ich habe erzählt, ich hatte einen Wasserschaden in meiner Wohnung, kompletter Wasserschaden und ist nichts passiert, alles noch nass, alles noch schimmelig, alles irgendwie muffig und dann wollte ich tatsächlich am Rosenmontag wollte ich desinfizieren, dachte ich desinfiziere jetzt zumindest mal, damit es nicht alles zuschimmelt, habe dann tatsächlich aber gemerkt, oh alle Läden haben zu und dachte dann, naja desinfizieren kannst du ja auch mit Alkohol. Und Rosenmontag und Alkohol gehen Hand in Hand. Das passt ja zusammen. Ja. Und dann stand ich schön am Kiosk in einer langen Schlange von irgendwie maskierten, kostümierten Leuten, vor mir Biene Maya, hinter mir Haribo Colorado Tüte und ich mittendrin. Was hat die Colorado Tüte bestellt? Bist du noch so lange geblieben? Es war mir sehr ungeheblich, aber das ist eine gute Frage. Ich hätte gerne Packung tutti froh, die. Ich gehe mit der Kritschlecken bitte. Und dann so alle drehen sich um und denken, warum? Hast du das nicht bekommen, das Kostüm, das du eigentlich wolltest? War das eine Sammelbestellung und die wurden aufgeteilt im Freundeskreis, die Kostüme. Hast du vielleicht heute schon so viel Colorado gegessen, dass du dessen überrüstig bist? Weil jeder, wenn du an jemandem vorbeiläufst und du hast eine Colorado-Tüte und jemand hat ein Colorado-Kostüm an, dem wird was angeboten. Das ist altes byzantinisches Moralrecht. Ja, das ist mit Giftrecht, das ist ganz klar. Deswegen kann gut sein, dass das überrüstig war. Aber ich stand da, jeder hatte eine dicke Flasche Alkohol in der Hand, ich hatte eine riesige Flasche Wodka in der Hand.
Aber das Witzige ist, du wächst ja nicht wie ein Karnevalist. Du läufst dann durch die Stadt, wie ich dich kenne, auch so ein bisschen in deinem Tunnel Kopfhörer auf, der davon nichts mitbekommt. Konzentrierter Blick, aka, fasst mich nicht an, ich hasse euch alle Blick und du klopfst da sehr streng und ein bisschen sauer rum, stellt sich dann an eine Kioskschlange an, wo vor die besoffenen Leute sind, hinter die besoffenen Leute. Alle im Party-Modus, wir haben alle eine Flasche Wodka in der Hand. Und du bestellst das, was man am wenigsten erwartet. Selbst du, die denken, was bestellt er jetzt, irgendwie Ohrstöpsel oder so, wo ich hinlegen kann. Nein, Helika, eine Flasche Wodka bitte. Und ich dachte mir, ich bin wahrscheinlich der Einzige, der plant damit, seine Wohnung zu desinfizieren. Oder nicht. Kann auch sein, dass die Rumbiene Maja vorne mir auch gesagt hat, scheiße, mein Waschbecken ist zugeschimmelt, mein Bienenstock ist voller Schimmel, ich muss was mitbringen, irgendwie die Königin hat mich geschickt, ich muss vielleicht nochmal da irgendwie mal desinfizieren und jetzt stinkt meine ganze Wohnung nach Wodka. Ja, Rosenmunder in Köln, eigentlich, ich finde, jetzt, ich will dein Problem nicht ins Lächerliche ziehen oder sowas, ich will nur sagen, ich will nur sagen, ich habe verloren gegen das flüssigste Element Wasser, Wasser 1, Florentin 0. Ich glaube nicht, dass Wasser das flüssigste Element ist. Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, gelbe Karte. Ich dachte jetzt von den vier Elementen Wasser, Stein, Feuer, Luft. Ja, grüne Karte. Okay. Ich möchte nur sagen, jeder im Freundeskreis braucht jemanden mit einem Wasserschaden. Okay. Dann bin ich ja froh, dass ich jetzt der für dich sein kann. Ja, weil es hilft. Es hilft enorm. Es hilft mir zu checken, alles ist besser als Wasserschaden.
Mein Leben könnte wesentlich schlimmer sein. Mein Leben könnte schlimmer sein. Und es gibt fast nichts Schlimmeres als Wasserschaden. Also es macht alles kaputt, alles was du besitzt ist kaputt, alles stinkt, du kannst nicht mehr schlafen, deine Wohnung verloren.
Nur ist nur Scheisse damit verbunden. Ich meine, als Freund muss man aber auch nicht helfen, weil es ist eh schon das Kind in den Brunnen gefallen. Also es ist wie so für alle Außenstehenden der Beweis, ah, ich habe mein Leben mehr im Griff. Ja. Du kannst ja nichts dafür, das ist auch so das Ding. Also nee, aber absolut nicht. Finde ich völlig richtig, dass mein Leid alle anderen so ein bisschen erhebt. Also dass alle anderen sich durch mich sozusagen an mir reflektieren können. Ich glaube, so ging es uns vielen, als du Rückenschmerzen hattest, als du richtig gelitten hast und wir uns alle gefreut haben. So, yes, ich habe das nicht, ich habe das nicht, oh Stefan, das tut mir leid, aber ich habe das nicht. Ja, gut, dass es nichts Materielles ist. Es ist jetzt nicht wie bei dir materiell ausfassbar. Ich hab das nicht, ich kann meinen Rücken bewegen. Ich weiß nicht, wie bei Gesundheit jetzt so schwer zu machen sollte. Oh, links, oh, rechts, oh, mal strecken, vorne, hinten, vorne, hinten, kann ich machen, ohne Schmerz. Ohne Schmerz. Stefan geht's richtig schlecht. Je schlechter es Stefan geht, desto besser geht's mir. Oh, okay. Wenn es Stefan richtig... Vielleicht sollte ich nochmal seine Kniescheiben zertrümmeln. Nochmal? Du warst das! Was? Hast du mich doch nicht an der Silhouette erkannt? Ich hätte schwören können, es war jemand anderes. Ich hatte nämlich mein Colorado-Kostüm unter dem Latex-Kostüm an. Und so habe ich dich gefobbt am Ende des Tages. War es eine Colorado-Tüte oder war es der Inhalt von Colorado? Es war eine Colorado-Tüte, wo ich mich auch frage, wie sehen die Lizenzverhandlungen da aus? Also kommt da irgendjemand ein Typ, der sagt, ich habe jetzt einfach zwei Fetzen Stoff, billigst, billigst Stoff. Hallo Herr Haribo, Herr Richter, dürfen wir da ihr Logo draufdrucken? Es kostet 4,99 Euro auf Amazon, es wird unter absoluten menschenverachtenden Bedingungen hergestellt, es wird einmal getragen, liegt dann im Dreck, liegt dann einfach in einer Pfütze in der Kölner Innenstadt, wo wahrscheinlich noch draufgebrochen wird. Da wäre ihr Logo drauf, ihr Produkt, das ja primär für Kinder gedacht ist, sprich sie haben dann Heerscharen von jungen oder mittelalten Männern, die stockbesoffen kotzend in ihrem Produkt durch die Kölner Innenschallstadt wanken. Können wir das produzieren, ja oder nein, Herr Richter? Sie könnten ja, wir könnten ja folgende sagen, von den 4,99 Euro, da machen wir 20 Cent Profit. Mit diesen 20 Cent kriegen sie zwei Cent ab. Zwei Cent, dafür wird ihr Markenname komplett durch den Dreck gezogen, wirklich bekotzt, besudelt. Wir haben teilweise im absoluten Volldelirium Ereignisse öffentlichen Ärgernisses, also wir haben dort sexuelle Handlungen, wir haben dort Vandalismus, gewalttätige Handlungen in einem Kostüm. Aber zwei Cent. Genau, zwei Cent pro Kostüm. Was sagst du, Grima Schlangenzunge? Ja, tu es, tu es, Richter, tu es!
Der sich bis dahin sehr höflich zurückgehalten hat, nichts gesagt hat. Aber in voller Aufregung da saß. Ja, ja, ja! Und dann sagt König Theoden Riegel. Der Typ ist genau der richtige Berater für mich. I want this guy. Der mit den schwarzen Haaren, der mit der ungesunden Hautfarbe, der komplett schwarz angezogen ist, nach Ork stinkt und offenbar ein Anhänger Sarumans ist. Take it. Ist auch ein Sketch, oder? Bewerbungsgespräch bei Theoden. So, ich suche einen neuen Berater und dann kommt Griemer Schlangenzunge rein. König Theoden, wir haben die besten Berater des Landes, wir sind die ganzen, die ganze Riddermark abgeritten und für sie, König euch, wie spricht man, für euch, König Theoden. Ja, wir brauchen dringend neue Leute, also der muss schon mal weg, sie werden als erstes ersetzt, sie werden, Theoden! Rohr nicht so hoch. Euer Ehren. Raus, weg, next. Der Typ direkt mal gefeuert. Eure Majestät, wir sind durch die ganze Rädersmarke ritten, um für euch den besten Berater zu bringen. Wir haben hier die besten fünfzig Mann und Frauen versammelt. Sie sind wirklich wie schlag den rabkandidaten wo man sich fragt wie kriegen die kriegt man so viele hobbys in einen scheiss leben rein und hier sind sie ich bin hendrik ich bin 24 ich mache kraft und karate und Wrestling und Martial Arts. Wo siehst du dich in fünf Jahren? Bundeskanzler oder so, also zumindest ein hochrangiger Politiker oder irgendwie so Bundeswehroffizier oder sowas, weil ich alles kann. Was würdest du als deine grösste Schwäche bezeichnen? Meine vielen Stärken. Okay, alles klar. Die sind schwer, schwer ich finde es schwer mich zu spezialisieren
ja gut danke hendrik ich habe ich habe natürlich ein master in beratung okay super danke hendrik schön dass du da warst dankeschön ja und dann hier mit den nächsten hallo mein name ist die rima schlangenzunge hallo ja was haben sie für qualifikationen Ich kann sehr gut Getränke brauen, fiese Gifte, grün belobernde, schreckliche Substanzen, die den Feind töten. Und wo sehen Sie sich in fünf Jahren? Als Alleinherrscher Rohans. Okay, was würden Sie als Ihre grösste Schwäche bezeichnen? Meine Abhängigkeit gegenüber dem dunklen Lord. Alles klar, Sie sind eingestellt. So wird das wahrscheinlich abgelaufen sein. So wird es abgelaufen sein, ja, völlig richtig. Ja, wir wissen es nicht. Wir wissen es nicht, wir werden es wahrscheinlich nie erfahren. Vielleicht werden noch mal die Liedezines nachgedreht. Ich weiß nicht, ob man das macht beim Film, dass man nach dem Film noch mal sagt, Mensch, das hat so viel Spaß gemacht. Lass uns einfach noch ein paar Szenen drehen, oder? Wie gespannt bist du auf Francis Ford Coppolas neuen Film? Sehr. Heute kam das erste Foto raus, sein neuer Film. Also das ist schon eine neue Evolution. Also man ist weg vom Trailer, dann irgendwann hin zum Teaser-Trailer, ein Trailer zum Trailer, dann gibt es so Snippets, die sind dann sozusagen so ein Teaser-Teaser-Trailer und jetzt ist man schon beim Foto, wo einfach nur Megalopolis der Filmtitel und unten steht darunter Directed by Francis Ford Coppola. Und irgendwann einfach nur noch so, hier, hast du schon gesehen, zum neuen Film, ja lass mal abspielen wie das war es
zeig mal den bildschirm wie es hat kein bild es hat kein bild eine sekunde lang mp3 ist ein ausschlag aus dem film oder ist es nicht nur ein ausschlag aus dem trailer okay können wir noch mal abspielen okay aber es ist nicht ganz klar irgendwie dramatisch zu sein Was ist jemand, ist es Dune?
Nee, wir wissen es nicht.
Ich bin auch nicht dabei.
Kein Titel, es steht einfach nur Teaser-slash-Final-MTG. MTG? MTG MP3. MTG MP3, Magic the Gathering. Moment mal, Francis Ford Coppola verfilmt Magic the Gathering. Ja. Wow. Okay, das wäre mal eine Ankündigung. Da würde ich mir mal ein Deck bauen. Ich würde mir ein Francis Ford Coppola Deck bauen. Okay. Ich weiß jetzt leider gar nichts. Ich entschuldige mich im Voraus. Wer steht in der ersten Reihe in deinem Deck? Naja, also in Magic gibt es ja verschiedene Sets. Ja, fang ganz hinten an. Magic gibt es ja verschiedene, also es gibt fünf verschiedene Farben. Weiss, grün, blau, schwarz, grün, schwarz, blau. Und es gibt ja Sets und da gibt es Sets mit den Sets, das sind so 300 Karten, die so ein in sich schlüssiges Thema haben. Märchenwelt, Antike, Zauberschule, Zukunftskrieger, Zukunftskrieger und ein ja? Nein. Zombies. Nicht wirklich. Samurai-Anime angehauen. Die sind passend an da rein, alles klar. Und dann gab es ein Set Gangstertiere. Gangstertiere. Gangstertiere. Es gab ein Set, Streets of Carpena, das waren Gangstertiere, also Tiere, die Gangster sind.
Okay, und da darf ich direkt...
Mafia-Dachse!
Yakuza-Lizards. Jacuzzi-Füchse. So, und dann die Fans, jetzt rechts, danke, danke. Wie, ich meine, ich meine die Konzeptphase, ich meine, okay, wir müssen 300 Karten designen zum Thema Jacuzzi-Füchse. Also wir haben, eines ist klar. Der, der, der, die Hauptkarte, die die alle wollen, die ist halt, wo Fantastic Fox, Jacuzzi, Jacuzzi. Ist sein Kopf nass oder ist er wirklich nur in den Jacuzzi gegangen? Das ist trockener Fuchs im nassen Jacuzzi. Okay, dann wie wäre es mit einem Artefakt-Bademantel vielleicht? Artefaktkarte, Bademantel? Ja, Badeshorts. Dann vielleicht sowas. Ausrüstung, gibt es sowas, Ausrüstungskarten? Ja, Ausrüstungskarten, Equipment, Badeshorts finde ich gut. Wo man sich auch fragt, okay, was hat er ohne diese Ausrüstung, geht er nackt ohne diese Ausrüstungskarte in den Pool? Ja. Wissen wir nicht. Finde ich gut. Dann sowas wie ein Zauber oder so, Kaltbad, Abhärten, Abkalten, dass eine Kreatur vielleicht verstärkt wird. Ja, dann so Blubber, Blubberblasen. Blubberblasen, wo kommen die Blasen her? Vielleicht so eine schwarze Zauberkarte? Oder Fische, die machen im Wasser. Also alle müssen ein bisschen auskussend. Ah, jetzt verstehe ich's, weil es so eine Fantasy-Jacuzzi ist. Das ist gar kein mechanischer, klassischer Jacuzzi, sondern es sind ganz viele Fische,
die blubbern. Hast du bis... Ah, okay.
Sorry, du hast es gerade gesagt.
Was du nicht sagst, kann ich ja nicht verstehen.
Jetzt verstehe ich die skeptischen Blicke.
Du hast gedacht, ich meine,
Jacuzzi-Füchse im Sinne von Spa.
Nein. Ach so.
Oh, du Trottel.
Was ist, also es sind so Fische, die blubbern,
oder wie, so ein grosser Holzbottich? Ja, oder so alte so Geysire oder so, ja, voll Fantasy. Nee, verstehe ich nicht, ich kenne die Blicke. Ja, okay. Weißt du, die Fische, die beim Geysir so aufgeladen werden mit Blubberblasen und dann so verfrachtet werden oder so? Gut, Fische, ja, und dann werden die verfrachtet. Genau, da sind dann die Blubberblasen drin und dann sagt er, die Blasen werden weniger, mehr Blasen, mehr Blasen, mehr Blasen und dann kommen irgendwie, aber was sind das für Tiere, was sind die Dienertiere, was sind die Diener für Tiere? So Komodowarane. Komodowarane? Ja, sei, ja, sei. Und die haben dann so Kugelfische auf dem Rücken, so Rucksäcke. Umgeschnallt. Umgeschnallt? So Lederriemen, umgeschnallte Kästen, Kugelfische oben drauf. Aber so kippt einer so um. Werden die dann so in das Wasser, in den Jacuzzi reingeworfen oder werden die unten angeschlossen an irgendeiner Düse? An so einer furchtbaren Düserei, ja. Und dann werden die langsam ausgedrückt, die Kugelfische, und so kommen die Blöbelblasen in den Jacuzzi rein. Okay. Ja, aber zwei Karten. Deutscher Podcastpreis. For your consideration. For your consideration. Please consider it. Please fucking consider it. Consider this shitty idea. Consider this. Con-fucking-sider this! Aber auch Idee an Wizards of the Coast für neues Magic Set., for your consideration, for your consideration. If you don't consider this, I will consider something very different. I have a crowbar, I have a black latex suit and I will smash your knees! Hör auf, hör auf den Zydrohen, das habe ich ein paar Mal gesagt. Wir können den Zyduris nicht immer drohen., sorry. Das ist in die Knallhart. Wer droht, verliert. Aber das könnte ... Ich habe gerade das Gefühl, wir haben ein paar Lode verloren, inklusive auch mich verloren auf dem Weg, weil ich nicht mehr genau weiß, worum es geht. Es geht um ein Deck für Magic the Gathering, ein Spiel, was mir nicht sagt. Mit dem Thema Jacuzzi-Füchse. Mit dem Thema Jacuzzi-Füchse in Jacuzzis. Nach dem erfolgreichen Pui Pui Molka, Meerschweinchen sind Autos, sind jetzt Füchse sind Jacuzzis.
Mit Kugelfische Jacuzzis kann man auch als Kinderserie rausbringen, die Möglichkeiten sind da offen, Stefan.
Lass dich da bitte nicht abhalten. Eine Idee ist eine Idee ist eine Idee, egal welchem Medium man sie umsetzt, okay?
Serie, Kuscheltiere, Museum, alles möglich. Idee ist eine Idee, ist eine Idee. Ist eine Idee. Du hast halt oft Dinge, in denen du sagst, XY ist, XY ist, XY, man denkt so, er will wieder knallhart sein Sprichwort durchbringen, irgendwie, dass es so ein geflügeltes Wort wird. Ich will dir nur als Freund auf den Weg geben, dass du vielleicht irgendwie, keine Ahnung, mehr Wörter in diesem Satz zum Beispiel würden helfen.
Aber Idee ist eine Idee, ist eine Idee, ist ohne Kontext nicht zu verstehen. Und weißt du, das mag ich an dir. Ja. Weil ein Freund ist ein Freund ist ein Freund. Aber du verstehst doch, was ich meine. Ja, im Kontext jetzt, aber es ist so inhaltsleer. Manchmal ist die wichtigste Aussage leer.
Du! Das ist so inhaltsleer. Manchmal ist die wichtigste Aussage leer. Denn eine Aussage ist eine Aussage ist eine Aussage. Ich verstehe nicht, worauf du hinaus willst mit dieser Idee. Willst unbedingt was durchbringen. Ich kann auch nicht sagen, worum es geht, aber ich habe eine Idee. Ich habe eine Idee für ein technisches Gimmick. Das ist was wir gerade brauchen. Sorry, jetzt habe ich nicht Gimmick, es ist eine technische Hilfsstütze. Es ist ein Roboterarm, der masturbieren kann. Na, ne, ein bisschen uncooler, aber wichtiger. okay und ich möchte nicht sagen was es ist und habe jetzt angefangen zu recherchieren, ob es das schon in Entwicklung gibt. Meine Ingenieurfreunde, wer? Die mittlerweile auch nicht mehr so gerne ans Handy gehen, wenn du anrufst. Wer soll das sein? Stefan, das, was du uns letztens vorgestellt hast, gibt schon seit hunderten von Jahren und ist ein Sieb. Stefan, du hast nicht einfach ein Sieb erfunden, das gibt's einfach schon. Ich meine, hast du verstanden, dass es sehr kleine Löcher hat? Ja, das hast du mir stundenlang erklärt und ich habe am Ende sogar ein Sieb dir gezeigt, den ich schon habe. Das ist ein Prototyp, genau, so habe ich auch gedacht. Nein, das ist ein Sieb, den ich bei Ikea gekauft habe, den es schon gibt. Aber er hat jetzt nicht die Artgrösse der Löcher, wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe. Das ist die gleiche Idee. Was hast du denn diesmal? Was kommt denn diesmal? Naja, ich habe mir gedacht, piep, und dann kann man damit piep, aber wenn jetzt... Das ist eine geile Idee. Piep, dann muss man aufpassen, dass man piep. Ja, aber läufst du damit nicht Gefahr dann am Ende piep. Ja, das ist natürlich klar. Deswegen habe ich mir überlegt, dass man, wenn man piep, einfach piep. Weil es ist ja im Endeffekt eigentlich eine Kombination aus piep und piep. Nur halt in blau. Ja, das ist eine geniale Idee. Ich finde es richtig gut. Ja, richtig. So, und dann hat man mir gesagt. Hast du schon eine Idee für Namen? Ja, piep, pinke. Und dann hat man mir gesagt, du musst jetzt die Recherche beginnen, die Patentrecherche. Das war aber auch nur eine andere Beschreibung für, bitte hör auf mich anzurufen. Bitte, bitte lass mich in Ruhe. Stefan, da musst du jetzt mit der Recherche. Das war aber auch nur eine andere Beschreibung für Bitte hör auf mich an. Bitte, bitte lass mich in Ruhe.
Stefan, da musst du jetzt mit der Recherche beginnen, die nicht bei mir anfängt. Ich habe das Gefühl, derjenige hofft, dass es das schon ausgibt. Weil das ist eher auch Arbeit. Du Robert, wie mache ich ein Patent? Stefan, es ist jetzt halb zwölf Uhr nachts. aber die helfen mir jetzt also ich habe Also ich habe jetzt schon mit einer vom Patentamt geschrieben und die helfen mir jetzt bei der Recherche. Aber du musst, also wir müssen schon grob erahnen können, also ist es was für den Haushalt, für Verkehr, ist es was für die Küche, für die Küchengerät? Haushalt allgemein. Haushalt allgemein, Schlafzimmer? Nö, Haushalt allgemein hilft allgemein. Zum Saubermachen, Reinigen? Nein, nicht zum Reinigen. Es ist ein... Luft, lüften, Fenster, laden...
Nö, er hat gro hat was mit elektrizität zu tun okay ist es eine lampe nee aber kann dafür benutzt werden es ist ein ein ein elektronisches gimmick nicht gimmick eine hilfe hilfsleistung was zum fernet nicht mehr ins Detail gehen. Ist es eine Fernsteuerung, ist es so ein kleiner Roboterarm, mit dem man Knöpfe an und aus machen kann? Ne, ne, ne, ne. Es hilft aber, Dinge woanders zu benutzen zum Beispiel, aber mehr möchte ich jetzt auch nicht unbedingt zeigen. Dinge woanders zu benutzen? Also du kannst dann plötzlich einen Mixer auch im Wohnzimmer benutzen. So, zum Beispiel. Ist es ein Verlängerungskabel? So nämlich. Nein, aber es geht sehr in diese Richtung. Es geht sehr in diese Richtung. Es geht sehr in diese Richtung. Aber es gibt das, was ich machen möchte, hat einen sehr speziellen Umschiff, ein Problem, was es gibt. Und ich kann, aber da möchte ich aber nicht sagen. Aber es ist eine, ich finde die Idee super. Es müsste auch schon technisch gehen. Hier Patent Panning. Ist es Strom ohne Kabel? Sowas. Und jetzt geht es natürlich los. Jetzt beginnt die Patentrecherche und jetzt bin ich verloren. Also ich dachte, dass die Reise später, ich dachte, auf jeden Fall wird das nicht klappen und die Reise wird bald vorbei sein. Die Reise ist jetzt schon vorbei. Okay, bevor sie angefangen hat. Diese Datenbank, ich verstehe nicht mehr, weil ich dachte, es ist sowas wie Google und so wird es auch beschrieben, wo man dann oben eingibt das Thema, worum es geht und die Technik, die man dafür benutzt und dann drückt man auf Suchen, aber das finde ich schon nicht. Ich finde schon nicht diesen Button. Dann würde ich gerne ein neues Patent anmelden und zwar für eine einfach zu durchsuchende Patentdatenbank. Gibt es sowas schon? Ich vermute, wie ich es so gedacht habe. Wahrscheinlich nicht, wenn du es nicht findest. Aber das ist daran scheinbar, dass ich diese Lupe nicht finde, diesen Finden-Button schon nicht finde. Das ist so blöd an der Geschichte.
Einfach auf jeder Website an derselben Stelle sein.
Und was ist der Unterschied zwischen Google und dem?
Oder anderen Suchmaschinen?
Ja, was ist der Unterschied zwischen Patentrecherche, Deutschland und Google?
Sind die nicht alle auch irgendwo zu...ändern? Ich weiß nicht genau. Ich habe mich aber jetzt auch nicht so wirklich damit beschäftigt. Wie viele Patente gibt es denn? Sehr viele. Also wirklich im Hunderttausender-Bereich oder so Hunderte oder wie viele? Ich muss ja sehen, forscht da schon jemand dran? Hat da schon jemand den Headstart? Ohne jetzt jemandem zu sagen, was es genau ist. Genau. Also du musst in Rostock beim Institut anrufen und sagen, hallo, forscht jemand gerade an? Also jetzt sowas wie, also man kann es im Wohnzimmer verwenden. Also es ist sowas wie ein Piep, Piep, Piep, Piep, Piep, Sie machen Piep gerückt. Sie müssen es uns schon sagen, weil wir sind hier beim Patentamt, wir klauen ihn das nicht. Ja, aber es ist so wie Strom ohne Kabel, also so wie eine Art WLAN-Strom. Okay, Sie müssen es uns genau sagen. Eine Art WLAN-Strom, also du hast eine grosse Steckdose im Haus und das sendet den Strom an alle anderen. Haben Sie irgendeine Idee, wie es technisch funktionieren soll? Nur vielleicht. Nee, Sie müssen es uns genau sagen, weil sonst... Mit Strahlung. Ah, okay. Ha, jetzt habe ich es aufgeschrieben, eingereicht, auf meinen Namen. Nein! Auf meinen Namen. Ha, der Loser. Da muss man echt aufpassen, weil was ich machen würde, ist, ich würde Fake-Patentamte aufbauen und wo Leute reinkommen, genau, und dann kommen die rein und die sagen, ja klar, ich schreibe mir hier auf, hab aber die ganze Zeit Zeige und Mittelfinger gekreuzt. Genau, an der Tür hinten, also was die Leute nicht sehen, ist aber die Rückseite der Tür, durch die man geht, ist so ein großes Foto von meinen Fingern, von unseren Fingern, die wir beide gekreuzt haben, und das sehen die Leute nicht. Und dann gehen sie durch die Leute, durch die Tür und setzen sich hin in einem shady Büro, in einem shady ass dunklen Büro.
Ich habe hier Kernfusion, ich habe es geschafft, ich habe die Formel rausgekriegt, hier, ich möchte mein Patent anmelden.
Können Sie jetzt die Formel diktieren?
Das ist P, Energie ist gleich Strahlung, Betastrahlung durch Fusionskern, Masse ist gleich Lichtgeschwindigkeit mal Pi.
Haha! Was?
Schauen Sie an die Tür hinten!
Nein! Nein! Haha, Sie sind reingefallen auf Patnetamt. Punkt E. Patnetamt. Patnet. Das ist gemein, das ist richtig gemein. Aber man muss auch zahlen, wenn du ein Patent anmeldest, muss man auch zahlen. Ich wüsste gerne, ich dachte, ich kann euch die ganze Reise, ich kann nicht mitnehmen, ich dachte, ich hätte bis zu schon das fertige Produkt in der Hand, ich dachte, ich könnte euch zumindest sagen, wie diese Patentrecherche funktioniert, ich finde den Suchbutton nicht. Also du, was du uns eigentlich mitteilen möchtest, ist, du brauchst Hilfe dabei, den Suchbutton zu finden auf der Patent-Datenbank-Recherche-Seite. Ich glaube, es ist einfach, ich glaube, da gab es so einen Button, aber ich habe keine Ergebnisse gefunden, ich bin schon nicht bei den Ergebnissen gelandet. Es ist immer so hoch und runter gerutscht, die ganze Website, ich weiß nicht warum, was da los ist. Ja und rechts, da musst du rechts auf scrollen, auf das Scrollbar.
Und das Mausrad war auch verklebt.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist ohnehin.
Wann hast du das letzte Mal mit dem Seitengreifer gescrollt?
Ich erinnere mich noch an eine Situation, so eine Art, sagen wir mal, Uniseminarsituation,
wo lauter junge Leute sitzen da und der Dozent kommt so rein, macht seine Präsentation auf und hat da so ein langes Dokument und geht mit der Maus ganz rechts an die Seite. Und die Studenten wurden alle schon ein bisschen nervös. Das passiert jetzt hier nicht. Und er drückt auf diesen Schieberegler und zieht runter und alle so, what the fuck, wie macht der das? Das ist auch so ein kleiner Balken und ist so viel zu ungenau.
So ein hundert Seiten Paper.
Und er rutscht auf Seite 80, ach nee, Moment, ich wollte auf Seite 2. Hin und her. Und da war schon der Spoiler, Materie stirbt. Oh nein, und es war wirklich, da ging so ein Raunen durch den Raum, wo man wirklich merkte, das ist eine Generationen Schlucht, die sich da gerade auftut. wohin gehen wir haben millennialsials haben ja noch dieses Scrollen-Touchpad, aber nächste Generation vielleicht nur noch dieses Scrollen auf dem Handy. Ja, es ist ja gerade noch diese Videos, die so viral gehen, wo man so eine Wand hat und dann hat man ein Kind rechts und einen älteren Menschen zum Beispiel links und dann fragt man mimt mal ein Telefonat und es ist ja immer noch bei uns in der Generation, hat man schon den Daumen und den Kleinfinger ausgestreckt. Und so telefoniert man, hält man ans Ohr. Das ist ja das Telefonzeichen. Kinder zeigen schon das Handy an, das iPhone an. Aber das ist schon spannend, weil der Ältere, der Boomer, imitiert ja den gesamten Kopfhörer mit seiner Hand, wohingegen der Junge das Halten, also der hat ein Fantasieobjekt in der Hand, wobei der andere das Objekt selber mimet. Das ist ja ganz interessant, das ist ja eine ganz andere Art der Darstellung, des Spielens. Ja, in gewisser Weise kann man ja ... Ob du die Person so machst oder ob du so tust, als ob du sie halten würdest.
Ja, haben wir ja beim Improv-Training, also generell beim Improv-Theater ist es ja auch so, dass man die Dinge mimen soll und nicht halten soll. Da wurde uns gesagt, macht eine Pistole nicht so, sondern tut so, als hättet ihr sie in der Hand. Ich finde nur spannend, also in gewisser, was sagt das über unsere, über diese Generation aus? Also ist das Handy so weit Teil von uns geworden, dass man es nicht mehr darstellen muss? Aber um ehrlich zu sein, mich wundert schon, dass die das Handy ans Ohr halten. Weil ich habe das Gefühl, das Moderne ist ja eigentlich eher so vor den Mund, so Sprachnachricht oder so vor sich. Und jetzt Mima, leg mal auf, wie du auflegen würdest. Ach so, alles klar. Ja, nein, naja, okay. Nein, bitte, ich kann skippen, bis zum Auflegen. Okay, weil ich sag immer, ich liebe dich und du sagst dann tschüss. Ja, alles klar. Ja, ich liebe dich. Tschüss. So, du machst den. Den, ja. Und weißt du, was das Kind gemacht hat? Auf den Hänger, ja. So, jetzt wird es sehr spannend für alle Leute, die uns nur hören. Wow! Es nimmt das Handy vom Ohr, guckt drauf und drückt mit dem anderen Zeigefinger der anderen Hand unten auf den roten Knopf. Gemimstark. Stark, ne? Wahnsinn, ne? Wahnsinn. Und dann war auch, mach mal ein Foto. Mach mal ein Foto mit beiden Händen. Genau, ja oder so, genau. Und das Kind hat so gemacht.
Aber die Gesten sind lame, muss man wirklich sagen. Ja, ich finde die auch viel lamer. Die modernen Gesten sind lame mit so einem Handy irgendwie so, da ist so ein Äh oder auch den Vorhang so über den Kopf legen, damit es dunkel bleibt. Genau, bei dem Fotoapparat. Ja, bei der Kamera Obscura noch. und dann werden sie drehen. Sagt man ja auch, was filmt, dann dreht man noch so an der Seite, obwohl niemand von uns das... Mach mal die Scheiben von deinem Auto runter. Kurbel. Ja, lame alles, alles lame. Man kann sich kaum noch verständigen. Wir haben nur noch Knopfdrücke überall. Man kann sich kaum noch verständigen. Wir haben den Anschluss an die junge Generation komplett verloren. Thais ist verschollen, Thais wird seit vielen, vielen Tagen. Wir haben Thais im Metaverse verloren. Thais wird von Dominos gefangen gehalten, irgendwo da im Tiefkühlkeller zwischen den ganzen Teigbällen ist Thais gefangen, der Knebel gefesselt. Ab wann sollte man sagen, dass die Praktikantin verschollen ist? Also nur mal da draußen, gib uns mal so eine grobe Richtung, weil wir sind nicht so Praktikanten erfahren. Wir hatten bis jetzt erst eine, ja. Es ist die erste und die ist weg und wir wissen, wir können auch keine anderen fragen, deswegen da. So und deswegen wollte ich mal von euch fragen. Kriminalpolizei, wir konnten sie auch nicht. Wir können auch keinen neuen einstellen, weil wir haben ja noch eine. Ja, es ist eine bürgerische Falle, da. Obviously. Und deswegen, oh Gott, die unsympathischsten Loser-Menschen. Deswegen wollte ich euch mal da draußen fragen, ab wann glaubt ihr, sollte man eine Praktikantin vermisst melden? Ich habe auch eine Frage, weil ich lebe jetzt in einer Wohnung voller Schimmel, Pilz. Und ich habe mir überlegt, so, was ist, wenn der Pilz anfängt, mich zu kontrollieren. Also ich atme den ein und er lebt in mir, so dieses klassische Last-of-Us-Situation, so der Pilz übernimmt mich. Gibt ja Pilze in der Natur, die dann irgendwie so Tiere oder Käfer oder so übernehmen. Und ich hab mir echt überlegt, ab wann würdest du es merken, dass ich ein Pilz bin, also nicht mehr ich selber. Und würdest du es mir sagen, oder würdest du dann sagen, ich weiss jetzt mehr als, also würdest du das gegen mich verwenden, oder würdest du sagen, heyorent, ich glaube, du bist ein Pilz oder würdest du sagen, nee, ich sag's bewusst nicht und würde mich weiter observieren oder so oder mich geheim töten, ab wann würdest du es merken? Ich hab Angst, wenn ich sage, Florent, du bist ein Pilz, dass dein Handel, da musst du ja so weit vom Pilz ergriffen sein, dass ich das schon merke. Ja, genau. In diesem Stadium hätte ich die Angst, dass wenn ich sage, du bist ein Pilz, entweder ich umgebracht werde oder der Pilz auch mich übernimmt oder der Pilz den Wirt, Willwirt, abstoßt, tötet. Okay, so und deswegen würde ich dich erstmal observieren. Du hättest eine Vermutung, würdest du dir aber gar nicht äußern. Nee, ich würde eine Mentorfigur mir suchen und dann sozusagen von dieser Mentorfigur Dein Ingenieur Kumpel Robert nämlich mal. Genau, wenn er mich nicht, also bis er entblockt hat oder so. Ich habe das Gefühl, das Blocken, damit will er nur sagen, dass ich mal wieder vorbeikommen soll. Ja, der Call to Action sozusagen. Naja, jedenfalls würde ich dann versuchen, diese Mentorfigur zu fragen, was kann ich hier machen und würde dann den Pilz observieren, um dann im Hinterrücks umzubringen und dich zu retten, aber dich zu retten. Aha. Voranthin muss nämlich erhalten bleiben. Okay, du würdest versuchen, den Parasiten zu entfernen, ohne den Wirt zu töten. Schwierige Aufgabe. Als du mich gerade gefragt hast, aber glaubst du, dass ich ein Pilz bin und ob er merkt, habe ich verschiedene Gedanken dazu gehabt. Zum einen glaube ich, dass du schon sehr lange ein Pilz bist, weil du erzählst dir, wie du gelebt hast und so, und ich glaube nicht, dass jetzt erst Schimmel da ist. Äh, ja, okay. Also auch deine ganzen Bäder. Muss ich mir gefallen lassen, ja. So eine Vermutung muss ich mir gefallen lassen, ja. Die Bäder und dann diese offensichtliche Wassersanitärprobleme, was wir da eh schon hatten. Korrekt, ja. Ähm, von daher das und dann auch so, ich habe ja auch dann in New York, kriege ich ja mit mit wie du dich ernährst und sowas und dann
ist hauptsächlich sporen muss man das du esst hauptsächlich feuchte tapete tatsächlich hast du dir immer wieder gemacht oder sports gegessen ne da habe ich so gedacht du dein körper ist ready für gefahren also bei den ganzen amerikanischen produkten die du reingeballert hast, würde ich sagen, Schimmel ist kein fucking Problem für deinen Körper. Dein Organismus sagt, wir haben viel Schlimmeres erlebt. Du meinst so, der Pilz schleicht sich so in mich rein, macht die Tür auf zum Büro und da ist schon alles voller Pilz. Und er so, ja, setz dich, setz dich, nimm dir einen Platz. Genau, das ist ja Möglichkeit eins. Die haben dann so diese Cubicle-Büros. Setz dich, nehm dir einen Platz, nehm dir ein Headset und alle arbeiten schon. Ja, wir sind schon komplett drin, es ist so eine Hightech-Welt. Ja, auf die fünf, alles klar, ich leite sie weiter. Oben fliegt so eine Wuppertaler Schwebebahn-artige Wuhu, viel zu danken. Bip, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip. Okay, einmal in die vier siebzehn, hallo. Die vier siebzehn, wie kann ich Ihnen helfen? Ja gut, ich bin, ich wollte eigentlich hier den Laden übernehmen. Ich bin Viruspilz. Wir brauchen gerade keinen Pilz mehr. Wir haben eine Arbeitslosenquote von 0%, wir haben alle Probleme gelöst und leben seit Jahren glücklich und zufrieden in diesem Wert. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass sie schon jemand ist. Gar kein Problem. Wir können Ihnen deswegen einen kostenlosen Urlaub komplett bezahlt für vierzehn jahre auf dem sonnendeck anbieten super dankeschön auch kann ich eines von den t-shirts haben klar natürlich okay dankeschön vielen dank ja sehr freundlich machen sie es gut alles klar danke wiedersehen kostenlosen sofortrente alles klar dankeschön weil die alle probleme versteht ihr ja weil die alle schon lange da arbeiten, weil die schon lange da sind. Das entweder, oder aber der Pilz kommt rein und denkt so, ich bin schon überall reingekommen, kein Organismus der Welt konnte mich jemals lahmlegen oder mir die Grenzen aufweisen, spricht sehr weird, kommt dann rein und dann kommt so ein SEK-artiges, super Hightech-Kommando, weil dein Immunsystem so krass aufvorbereitet ist, weil es schon so viel Schwachsinn erlebt hat. Wir haben hier schon ganz anderes gesehen. Wir haben hier ganz andere Sachen gesehen und es ist einfach so ein SWAT-Team, du bist direkt umzingelt. Kann auch Sinn, eines von beiden, aber ich weiß nicht, ob ich beruhigt sein soll davon, dass du mir das nicht sagen würdest, dass ich ein Pilz bin, Was mich natürlich jetzt auch vermuten lässt, dass ich momentan jetzt aktuell schon Pilz bin und vielleicht noch so viel Bewusstsein und Kontrolle habe, dass ich diesen Gedanken überhaupt fassen kann. Vielleicht wird dieser Gedankengang nämlich mein Leben kosten, weil der Pilz sagt, oh, er kommt jetzt auf die Schliche. Okay, Idee, wenn du das Gefühl hast, du bist ein Pilz, brauchen wir ein Safety-Word, was du in den nächsten paar Folgen im Podcast sagst.
Okay.
Konsequenz zum Beispiel.
Ja, ich sag, okay.
Wenn du das Wort Konsequenz sagst, dann hat Flo, okay, da draußen.
Alle wissen es, ich weiss es auch.
Wenn ihr ihn auf der Strasse seht, könnt ihr ihn quasi überfallen.
Zugriff, genau.
Das ist der Zugriffbefehl, sobald ich das Safe-Word-Konsequenz sage, das zählt es nicht, sondern erst ab jetzt.
Genau. Wenn ich es sage, dann wisst ihr, Zugriff, er hat sich gerade als Pilz zu erkennen gegeben. Zugriff, Extermination. Genau. Alles klar. Ja, finde ich super. Also wenn du das Wort Konsequenz sagst, wenn Florian das Wort Konsequenz sagt, ab jetzt, in den, sagen wir mal, nächsten 50 Folgen, danach würde ich sagen, ist okay. Auskuriert, ja. Weil das dann auskuriert ist. Okay, alles klar, da bin ich sicher. Da hätte es sozusagen keine ... Du darfst aber dann nicht reagieren, ne? Du darfst nicht reagieren im Moment, weil du darfst ja ... Genau, du darfst dem Pilz nicht zeigen, dass er erkannt wurde, sondern du darfst in dem Moment nicht darauf reagieren, sondern einfach ganz normal mit mir weiter die Folge machen, sodass wir alle das sozusagen unter uns wissen und ich ausgeschaltet werden kann. Es gilt auch nicht der Plural, es gilt nur der Singular Konsequenz. Genau, alles klar. Super, okay, finde ich gut. Gut, finde ich gut, dass wir da alle jetzt auf dem selben Niveau sind, dann fühle ich mich schon sicherer, um in die nächste Woche zu gehen. Ich wünsche euch eine ganz, ganz tolle Woche. Ich auch. Viel Spaß bei allem, was ihr tut. Schaut mal, dass vielleicht nicht Wasser durch die Decke kommt und denkt über eine Houtsratsversicherung nach. Macht's gut, haut rein!
Wir haben ein paar Anbieter für euch. Tschüss!
Macht's gut, tschüss!
It's the worst
Bird Production!